des anciens salariés et d'autres
toujours en poste chez atos aux
clayes-sous-bois ont développé des
cancers du cerveau
révélée par complément d'enquêté affaire
fait grand bruit cette multinationale
spécialiste des services informatiques
est en plus des nombreux serveurs et
salles informatiques
entouré de trois antennes relais entre
2015 et 2019 sept cas de cancer rare du
cerveau ont été observés chez les
salariés y at il un lien avec les ondes
électromagnétiques présentes sur le site
personne ne peut le prouver aujourd'hui
des investigations sont toujours en
cours une enquête a été diligentée avec
la composition d'un groupe d' alerte en
santé du travail ce gast avait pour
objectif de mettre en place différentes
études au cours du premier trimestre
2009 un contenu de la suspension des
investigations dugast en raison de la
déclaration de la crise sanitaire liée à
l'épidémie de chorales à virus
madame le maire dé le déconfinement a
saisi officiellement par courrier en
date du 13 et du 20 mai 2020 le préfet
des yvelines et les autorités sanitaires
compétentes un changement de maire a élu
en juin 2020 mais la position reste la
même
les investigations du gaston repris et
un nouveau rendez vous est organisé avec
la mairie dans le mois mais cette
commune n'est pas la seule concernée
au total dans les villes des
clayes-sous-bois de villepreux et de
plaisir dix autres cas de cancers
similaires ont été recensés moi en tant
que maire j'ai deux responsabilités la
première allée au niveau de la santé
avec les mesurer avec les compétences je
dirais que sur lesquels je m'appuie
parce que c'est pas moi qui ai les
compétences particulières mais on
s'appuie sur des compétences de
scientifiques et puis d'un autre côté on
a aussi la responsabilité de pouvoir
faire travailler les entreprises et les
privés qui en ont besoin surtout en
cette période
la mairie attend donc les conclusions
des investigations et se dit prête à
agir
qui des personnes qu'ils soient malades
indéniablement ça c'est certain
maintenant si si on devait se rendre
compte que ces installations devaient
développer ce genre de choses bien
évidemment je serai la première à
trouver les solutions dans la mesure de
mes capacités en tout cas en tant que
maire de son côté atos n'a pas souhaité
répondre pour le moment à nos
sollicitations